i
[Música]
[Aplausos]
bienvenidos a corresponsales del
programa de france 24 que los invita a
dar una vuelta al mundo de la mano de
nuestra red de periodistas comenzamos
esta emisión en el sáhara occidental
desde la ruptura del alto el fuego entre
marruecos y el frente polisario en
noviembre de 2020 esta región que está
en un 80 por ciento controlada por
marruecos ha vuelto a un estado de
guerra miles de jóvenes saharauis se han
levantado en armas después de 30 años de
un plan de paz con rabat y en esta nueva
fase el frente polisario cuenta con el
apoyo de argelia país que ha roto
relaciones con su vecino y rival
marruecos y nuestra enviada especial
este lunes nos tiene la historia
omar day de está al frente de la línea
de batalla del sáhara occidental' tan
sólo nueve kilómetros nos separan del
ejército enemigo es su primera misión
militar
en
las posiciones militares del ejército
una vez de ocupación marroquí
tenemos que ser muy muy cuidadosas con
nuestro movimiento porque cada un error
un simple error nos puede pagar la vida
el sáhara occidental' vuelve a estar en
guerra tras la ruptura del alto el fuego
por una de las partes beligerantes el 18
noviembre de 2020 ahora los que llevan
al fusil son los nietos de aquellos que
lucharon junto en general a valid por la
independencia de estos territorios
cuando españa se retiró en 1976
las academias militares están llenas hay
mucho apoyo de la juventud nuestros
jóvenes están más preparados muchos
universitarios
tengo confianza en esa nueva etapa de la
guerra
jóvenes como omar nacidos en los
campamentos de refugiados han parado sus
estudios para unirse a las filas del
frente polisario y luchar por la
liberación de un país que prácticamente
no conocen ya que el 80 por ciento del
territorio saharaui está ocupado por
marruecos como el líder de uno de los
líderes de la revolución saharaui la
revolución no es opciones si no es
responsabilidad entonces la nueva
generación de los saharauis los jóvenes
saharauis los intelectuales y la
vanguardia saharaui tiene una gran
responsabilidad
el td en los campamentos contrasta con
las ráfagas de actividad militar que
hemos dejado atrás la zozobra se cuela
los huecos de las casas de adobe y
tiendas de lona diseminadas en el
inmenso desierto de arena y basura ahora
más que nunca boba mohamed alí mira con
inquietud del mañana volvemos ya a
nuestras casas y vivimos y dejamos este
refugiado porque hemos vivido tan
muchos años aquí en los campamentos y
y ya queremos ya nuestra independencia
el frente polisario los alimenta desde
pequeños de patriotismo y de té muy
azucarado la relación de las
hostilidades ha desempolvado la causa
saharaui y su lucha por la
autodeterminación
no tenemos ánimo de reproducir otros 30
tampoco la situación en la región lo
permiten en el sáhara occidental tampoco
en la región porque sabemos lo que se
vivió y las rupturas de relaciones
diplomáticas entre argelia y marruecos y
en la guerra de sáhara occidental' el
líder del frente polisario brahin galli
que se ha recuperado de el coronavirus
ahora ha aparecido en los campamentos
para infundir fuerza a los jóvenes que
ahora han de tomar el relevo
generacional para continuar con la lucha
por la independencia una nueva guerra en
las arenas del desierto ha puesto fin a
30 años de proceso de paz y aleja las
esperanzas de 170 mil refugiados
saharauis que sueñan con vivir en una
nación libre después de 45 años
esperando en los campamentos argelinos
de tindúf
el presidente turco recep tayyp erdogán
dio marcha atrás con su reciente amenaza
de expulsar a 10 embajadores del país
entre ellos los de naciones como eeuu
francia o reino unido- lo que habría
desatado una muy profunda crisis
diplomática con sus aliados occidentales
entretanto dentro del país erdogán
mantiene las riendas de la nación con
mano de hierro aumentando los ataques
contra opositores y activistas y
silenciando la crítica una estudiante y
un abogado que han sido directamente
víctimas de los ataques de las fuerzas
de seguridad del gobierno y que han sido
tachados de terroristas le contaron a
france24 cómo se vive la persecución
dentro de turquía y nuestro corresponsal
adrià rocha nos tiene sus historias
una estudiante universitaria presintió
lo que estaba por venir la policía la
detuvo en una manifestación junto con su
amiga
les pegaron muy fuerte directamente nos
detuvieron metiendo una paliza a todos y
nos esposaron fue allí donde me hicieron
lo de mi ojo y algunos de mis compañeros
tienen heridas parecidas sonia lesión de
lo pensado en journal isla el mismo
mishra participó en las protestas de la
universidad del bósforo ocurridas el año
pasado tras el descontento de los
estudiantes con la imposición de un
nuevo rector nombrado por el presidente
turco recep tayip erdogán
en el último año la arremetida contra
activistas y opositores se ha
incrementado sustancialmente en turquía
ardón represión o oposición
erdogán reprime la oposición y polariza
el país porque su estilo político se
apoya plenaria en formas autoritarias
como dividir y reprimir toda oposición
entre evans un
autoritario en beige like the white and
press
el abogado es grupal lo ha sufrido
personalmente yo solo soy un ejemplo que
muestra cómo funciona el sistema
judicial de treki a como yo 38 mil
personas han sido juzgadas en los
últimos años por insultos al presidente
yo fui acusado mientras ejercía una
defensa judicial y mi caso muestra
exactamente como la ley y la justicia ha
desaparecido en turquía pero los
manifestantes y activistas están
decididos a mantener su voz de protesta
pese a que desde el gobierno se les
llame terroristas nos tienen miedo
tienen miedo de nuestra lucha porque es
una protesta real empezada por
estudiantes es decidida y hemos
demostrado que somos valientes ante su
poder y su presión hagan lo que hagan si
no hemos abandonado nuestra lucha y por
eso quieren terminar con nosotros y nos
atacan por el momento mishra y otros
activistas siguen presionados por el
gobierno turco albergan la esperanza de
que en algo más de un año cuando se
celebren elecciones la actual represión
de erdogán no le permita mantenerse en
el poder
continúan las tensiones entre la unión
europea y belarús el presidente de ese
país alexandr lukashenko ha sido
señalado por los europeos de
presuntamente permitir que solicitantes
de asilo provenientes de áfrica medio
oriente y afganistán organicen desde
minsk la capital bielorrusa su viaje
hacia la frontera con el bloque
comunitario a donde cruzan de manera
irregular desde bruselas aseguran que
lukashenko está utilizando los migrantes
como un arma política en respuesta a las
sanciones que han sido impuestas a su
gobierno consecuencia de las constantes
violaciones a los derechos humanos en
belarús mientras tanto los migrantes
enfrentan situaciones cada vez más
difíciles y que tienden a empeorar de
cara a la llegada del invierno ellos lo
lograron pero muchos otros no
completaron el peligroso viaje de
belarús a alemania hay a ahmed y otros
sirios dicen que mantenerse unidos los
ayudo a superar los peligros después de
aterrizar en el aeropuerto de minsk
tardaron 20 días en cruzar la frontera
de belarús con polonia
que no fue del todo recto tienes que
atravesar selvas atravesar muchos campos
difíciles
no es seguro y nos sorprendió la
cantidad de personas que hay allí sobre
todo los niños
estos son sólo algunos de los 5000
migrantes que llegaron a alemania desde
septiembre este centro de recepción de
asilo cerca de la frontera con polonia
tuvo que aumentar los recursos para
acogerlos a todos
tuvimos que instalar nuevos contenedores
y carpas y no muy lejos de aquí
alquilamos un edificio que puede
albergar a 500 personas más eso debería
ser suficiente por ahora
los migrantes que llegan aquí son
examinados y luego registrados el
director del centro dice que algunos han
pagado hasta dos mil dólares por el
viaje
sea cual sea su país de origen todos nos
dicen que llegaron a minsk en avión
y luego compran una visa para belarús y
se los atiende hasta la frontera
alemania acusa al presidente de belarús
alexander lukashenko y organizar otra
crisis migratoria el jefe del sindicato
de la policía federal dice que todo
indica que esa es la causa
las cifras que estamos viendo ahora son
casi idénticas a las que teníamos en la
frontera con austria en 2013 cuando
comenzó la crisis migratoria todo eso
viene desde el 2015 cuando las cosas se
salieron de control y se volvieron
caóticas así que tenemos que actuar
ahora
alemania y polonia están impulsando
patrullas fronterizas conjuntas y
adicionalmente se han desplegado casi
1000 policías alemanes
la localidad de tabacundo en ecuador es
conocida como la capital mundial de la
rosa y es que en efecto las flores son
el principal rubro de exportación de
este país andino sin embargo desde ya un
floricultor y sus tres socios tienen la
mirada puesta en un nuevo y jugosa
negocio el del cannabis medicinal cuya
producción distribución y
comercialización está permitida en el
país desde el 2019 ellos abrirán el
primer centro de salud de ecuador con
productos a base de cannabis y nuestro
corresponsal gustavo ortega nos trae su
historia
crees ser siembra rosas en este puerto
desde hace 35 años
pero ha decidido cambiarse de rubro
y apostar al cannabis para uso medicinal
las hectáreas que se van a migrar a
cannabis con hectáreas nuevas de rosas
no tengo ninguna dejar las rosas pero sí
creo que esto es una industria con un
potencial enorme y las ventajas que
tiene ecuador como país
tiene ventajas que ningún otro país del
mundo las tiene las rosas son el
principal producto de exportación en
lengua duro sin embargo con la reforma
del código orgánico integral penal se ha
abierto una nueva línea de negocios a
los productores y trabajo para la mano
de obra pero aún hay barreras por
derribar al principio los estigmas que
decían que no que debería retirarme
porque había supuestamente que era la
planta la que decían que era mala que
nos servía que no se montón estigmas que
le decía pero con el tiempo
fuimos viendo que no era cierto
laboratorios y ecuatorianos ya están
preparando medicamentos con cannabis
películas de epilepsia agradece que ya
esté disponible esta opción medicinal en
su país que yo me caigo me quedo en un
piso y después como que reaccionó
con un poco del dolor de cabeza y
entonces no me he dado cuenta de eso
pero ahora con las gotitas he podido
controlarlo mucho mejor
no he podido ya no me da en la mañana en
la noche pocas veces esto de aquí se
vende así klaus además de rosas ahora
vende sus recetas de cannabis y que el
mercado por ahora se mantendrá con los
dos futuros a la espera de resultados
económicos para ver si se concentra sólo
en este nuevo negocio
gracias por acompañarnos en esta nueva
edición de corresponsales nos damos cita
la próxima semana siga con más
información en france 24 y france 24
puntocom